what's going on there reject nation we
are here today to watch superman and
lois kicking off season two we took a
while to get around to it we were
recovering some other shows that we
wanted to wrap up first and uh we
already get enough complaints about our
inconsistency of not delivering the
shows at expected times what a lot of
people don't realize is that you know
it's just the two of us we do have
youtube and patreon each one of these
shows even though we have help with the
reaction highlights we're still very
much involved with the edit and at bare
minimum each show that we cover yes it
only takes about 40 to 45 minutes to do
the reaction for it but to assemble the
whole video bare minimum of like three
to five hours anywhere on average with
that in mind we just needed some
comfortable time to be able to do this
we still want to figure out our schedule
with some other shows because i know
there's some amazing channels out there
like blind wave and normies who
mainly do tv where for us our best
performing videos on average throughout
the month of things that really help us
have a living are actually things that
are not tv reactions so you know fragile
balance yeah it's it's it's a balance we
have to strike like we got to about 600
000 subscribers before we ever started
covering tv you know so that's why we
took so long but here we are today if
you want to show your support by
becoming a super eject check us out on
patreon full-length watch lobster
superman and lobos will be over there as
well uh we obviously love the hell out
of the first season uh so if you can go
ahead and hit that like button that
would be very much appreciated you know
subscribe and get notified when our
reaction from the next superman and lois
is up the current plan right now i try
to give as much information these intros
as possible but a lot of people seem to
skip them is we want to get the first
three out of the way this week probably
we're gonna try to aim for like in every
other day upload see
when
it would be if it would be wednesday or
thursday but we'll keep you updated
we'll we'll keep you updated we're doing
all we can right now and we want to make
sure that we're able to enjoy what we're
covering as well
while also doing the behind-the-scenes
work that you guys don't need to concern
yourselves with let's get to it thanks
to the boys of prepper for helping us
edit these down
[Music]
mom
no no no no
oh no
that's not your mother
let me explain okay
oh she has to say something
he's recapping all of season one right
now
so i came to this earth and i was
originally trying to kill this superman
oh
whoa
something wrong
you'll um
you'll smell
[Laughter]
interesting cologne sweetie yeah you put
on the whole bottle there chief what's
that
it's a surprise for sarah you spending
all day with her just be home for dinner
yeah yeah
you know it's natalie's first day at
school today think you want to call her
what's your luck something clark i don't
know what to tell you she still won't
talk to me are you trying to
mother her
at least a few episodes
classic superman suits
last thing we need is smallville
becoming some sort of tourist trap just
because what happened here with morgan
hitch well it's helping the local
economy who cares a lot of us a lot of
us don't like the better when the town
was failing we got a lot of people that
are excited to see you
oh sophie
jordan
yeah me too
how was camp
yeah good i mean it was good to be there
it just felt a little different as a
counselor better
yeah everything
everything was better should do pot hook
up
yeah
boyfriend over the summer counter
slasher
be the final girl
oh you should put daniel's face on it
he'd make a super hot mayor no it
doesn't matter what he looks like sarah
he just needs to beat george dean and i
will work as hard as possible to make
sure that happens oh careful gregory
smith directed this
oh that's probably jordan
saw him walking up and grabbing the box
he's here right now yeah he smells
ridiculous
my mom's got this big daniel hart like
mayoral campaign event planned so
the house is gonna be pretty crowded
could you meet me at atlas pond in like
an hour
i have something i want to show you
oh what's her deal she got another
love interest
oh no hey i'm gonna walk down to
hubbard's farm ben wanted me to look at
the headers on his combine all right uh
yeah we'll just be hanging out then if
you just turn your girlfriend around for
a second
if you distract her please
oh here we go
look at the ripples on that suit
[Music]
what's going on here
[Music]
some like burrowing its way up
[Laughter]
jeez
what was [ __ ] him up hey you know
just allergies super allergies
that's beautiful
that's right
get a good look now who saved you
[Laughter]
[Music]
get back to football i just want to make
sure we don't attract any unwanted
attention you mean like the same kind
you get from flying around the world in
a steel war suit with superman
you get a helmet i'll pick up right here
when you get out
sure thing henry i'm gonna love her
[Laughter]
i wish you were dead
a lot easier before you showed up
thanks for going just okay
[Music]
oh
man
qb
that's why i gotta be faster than a
speeding bullet
speedy bullet
yes he's just arrived the whole reason
that i got this position is because i
was the one who knew everything about
you now it's very unclear to me that
actually
i know nothing about you lieutenant
anderson that's not true
i've got some comics for you but
american interests come first
lieutenant we've been over this i will
continue to do everything i can to help
the dod that's not a commitment it's the
best i can
do i need you home now
i have to go there are some terrorists
in trouble
in my home i need to get back to
beheading people
[Laughter]
is everything okay
she signaled for that you knew she was
here
yeah
you explain the birds and bees right now
i came home to find our
not even old enough to drive son in bed
half naked with candace jonathan come on
man
this is what is bothering me that you
left our 15 year old son home alone to
have sex and you're acting like this
isn't a big deal
not enough to use the elt no oh
that is for real emergencies lois not to
get me home to talk about some high
school hookup
you know what why didn't go to lana's
without me she's about to use kryptonite
on him
get out my kryptonite ring
[Laughter]
are you ready now
almost
just give me a sec
i mean not to crave your style or
anything this blindfold is really itchy
so will you bury me
it's clear you want it too
oh wow
how'd you light all those
i just wanted to do something nice for
you coming back
oh why is she so resistant she cheated
on him is everything all right i'm
feeling sort of crampy i i didn't know
of course you didn't i mean it's not
really something i text you about like
emotional cramps
my heart is cramping
see women are uh the mysterious
creatures ken
a lot of times where there's mystery
there's uh
there's danger and a tiny brain
interesting
listen if you'll excuse me i got some uh
sloppy ass shirt cocktails to deliver
that's amount of jealousy to attend to
i like them bonding we're different
well everyone else is basically the same
and living their best possible life i
mean just look at mom now lois is not
your mother and she is not living her
best life are all her lines going to be
delivered that way
for the first half of the season
[Laughter]
how'd it go with sarah
what's good this is great
i i just i don't want to talk about it
you can
can i just go up to my room now
we're you naked
and so you know i think we might get a
little talking through from dad later
about what
have you heard of sex oh no it's just
him and i have talked about this
repeatedly i'm sure you have i'm just
saying you might
want to check in with him hey
so he did say something like what the
[ __ ] did you tell corporal
this is just like working it's all over
again
it makes me feel like he's hiding
something from me but then acts like
somehow you're to blame for wanting to
know what's wrong exactly even though
all you're trying to do is help it turns
into some kind of argument and then that
makes you the bad guy are we still
talking about kyle the theme of the
episode are you two about to hook up it
was just
it's too much
yeah yeah wow he's insecure
i mean this be real kid is batting way
out of his league that you're hot as
hell
if i wasn't your dad
i think the best thing you do is just be
honest that wasn't terrible advice
that's kind of where i'm sitting the bar
as a dad
[Laughter]
she was my daughter in that other world
and seeing her standing there and
calling me
mom i felt nothing
and in that moment i finally realized
how my mom must have felt the day she
left us oh that's not the same thing
how a mother
could just
oh
abandon her children
and now i know
no that's
you are not your mother
what happened with natalie that's
that's a completely different thing
yes
no
[ __ ]
i get it that's rough that's [ __ ]
sucks
john called me dad the first time you
saw me
[Laughter]
i still catch myself trying to do it now
i'm gonna kick this earthquake's ass
just punch those pleats back into place
lady dropped all our popcorn
i think it's more than an earthquake
the water tower
oh
cool
when will things stop exploding at the
mine
oh
nice that was really cool how they
capture that
those are not civilians who the [ __ ] is
this
oh
no oh wow
[Music]
oh no
tremors seem to have stopped
for now that is messed up anderson who
are they
they're from our school your school
surely general lane told you that the
dod is training oh from last season yeah
what you asked for was my allegiance to
america and you refused because i gave
it to the world a long time ago
america needs to come first oh boy
where's tag at that crest you put on
their suit
it's not yours to give that's the most
recognizable symbol on the planet you
should have copyrighted it america can
have more than once to premiere
jeez what a dick i mean america does
come first guys that's right he did
exactly what he should have done all
right
superman's a commie thousand percent
screw the world
[Music]
um the martha can't bench that moment
since you left what i could have said or
done differently
is that why you kept calling to make
yourself feel better
[Music]
why would you want me in your life
because you seem wonderful
smart always lovely you're a survivor so
many reasons
i just think it'd be good for both of us
for in each other's lives
be nice
all the time that i'm spending with
daniel for the campaign
you know i'd rather be here with you
right even if my mug's not splattered
all over her t-shirt
even if your sexy mug is not splattered
all over a t-shirt
[Music]
look you guys are both 15 years old i
get wanting to be
intimate with someone
and it comes with some pretty adult
feelings that
you might not be ready for yet if and
when you guys have any questions
you can always come to us all right uh
or google
i think things are gonna get back to
normal around here
finally
yeah
funny you should mention
well i went to finally talk to natalie
and i realized i couldn't let her leave
again we're a mixed family now you sure
you're okay with this
and of course
happy to help a friend
oh you multiverse personality killed
them
[Laughter]
still a little weird every time i hear
that
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is going on he can hear
the score now
uh
what just
they just cut to black who was that
is it is it an alternate john henry
are they teasing
doomsday
[Music]
i
don't
didn't know
why that would be
i don't really know the superman
villains as well as i hope and that's
the best guess i got at this point it's
like a massive hand so i'm like doomsday
this is where my vibe goes this is gotta
be doomsday right this is as good as
mine i mean that would be a pretty bold
move for season two
i don't see any images from the comic
that line up with the gloves yeah all
right so not gonna talk for too long
because we got a couple more episodes to
go through here
but yeah watching on amazon it just like
ended there and then when we went back
to the cw app that was where it ends but
then it's just the logo shakes
i feel like it's doomsday
it would have to be doomsday
i'm gonna trust you on that one i don't
really know superman's gallery
that well
but
um
i don't know why it would be doomsday i
mean my mind went to some kind of
auxiliary kryptonian threat just because
like that's the is that the same mine
that had the x kryptonite last season
and everything and they were like using
to
you know as the catalyst for bringing
back kryptonians like maybe there's some
other remnant of that going on but
i mean usually
the threats for superman are linked back
to
actual kryptonian even morgan edge i
forgot his kryptonian name
zuul zoo there
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah that's why i was confused
too but then now we're seeing like that
whole thing with the school and tat was
the guy
getting um
uh enrolled in that school after
inheriting some powers i remember that
taro
you said tag and it took me there okay
yes
um so yeah what it had um that school
being brought up this new um
doa doa
d-o-d d-o-d yeah yeah yeah dead-on
[Laughter]
yeah this new dod person in charge i
think he's uh that's a cool way to flip
it or
before you had lois's dad in their
general lane where you can cooperate and
you draw some like family tension from
there
and uh how to really work together and
also be son-in-law father-in-law
but then here with this anderson
character i love the setup of him
because there's something very
antagonistic about him where it's like
he like i'm a fan of superman but really
he's uh he was just trying to figure out
any way he can to manipulate him to make
him the ultimate american soldier to
fight global threats and put america
first
which is a really interesting concept i
think that was like the the introduction
of that moment was really well done of
you you save people
but they're also north koreans with some
nuclear missiles it's not american
enough
i mean it's a good argument because even
here as a viewer i'm like could have at
least gotten rid of the nuclear warheads
yeah yeah and i love the way they talk
after that because you're like oh goody
yeah he saved the people but oh yeah
that's right what kind of sub is this
and yeah it's like how could he throw
him out into space or something but you
would think that superman would be you
know down on the concept you know not
for the concept of nuclear war you think
he might do something to dispose of them
but why americans allow nuclear warheads
well and that's another good encounter
this is good this is a good counter
argument if that's what this episode
focused on this is your time
just by the end of the season convince
the world to demobilize and just to
destroy all the nuclear weapons i think
that would be the best character arc
possible yeah but doomsday doomsday
that's right
coming up from the bottoms of the earth
forget the discussions uh yeah i mean i
i think that this is a solid
continuation of what we're picking up
from last season
um they have a good time jump here i
like the progression of lois's character
that's very you know like last season we
explored some of her family trauma they
like lost a child
and um also with you know her mother
being abandoned abandoning her
like they you saw her go to therapy last
season so it's a real character study
that they do of her and
you know what they had here i thought
was like the daughter character was uh
i'm not gonna say she was bad i was
worried that the writing of her would
get on my nerves yeah 100 like i i
really like the actress
but i was
i got hopeful by the end that she'll
become a more nuanced character because
the initial parts of this episode with
her were pretty much like exactly what
you would expect yeah just like angry
angsty teen
but you know with a couple of extra
details yeah multiverse travel but
we're not communicating or not listening
and yeah it's like they they sometimes
like tv just sucks at uh
writing a more
cool it's like take lois for example you
know
in a lot of ways she was what the [ __ ]
is the daughter's name
uh you mean lana's daughter oh natalie
sorry sorry uh
yeah i'm telling you clearly i'm talking
about sam right now
sarah yeah
good thing i'm glorified i was asking
you guys
natalie yeah did that last season called
sam you know i mean
there are a lot of sarahs and sams
across a lot of the properties that we
watched so it's um but natalie yeah
natalie i mean take take natalie and
then take
lois
like lois is kind of doing the same
thing you know like there's some [ __ ]
bothering her so she's all angsty and
mean and moody pushing everybody but
there's but you could tell there's like
so much more depth to that as opposed to
man you're just a whiny woman you know
yeah yeah you're just a kid who's angry
and doesn't know how to control that
emotion and i think that like granted we
don't know natalie all that well we only
saw her in flashbacks for
steel's character um
on their earth so we don't really know
her that well but it at the same time
like the the writing and the direction
of the acting wasn't really helping in
those scenes yeah you think she'd be a
little more conscientious for like the
she's seen like action back home and
she's well aware of like the peril that
her dad deals with so i feel like she'd
be a little more aware of her
surroundings they're just angry and
and upset versus any like level of
conflict
yeah like not like nuanced conflict yeah
nuanced conflict of readjustment so yeah
i thought that was uh
you know i thought it might have been
more interesting if it was like i'm
trying i'm trying to get adjusted this
is just really hard for like at a loss
yeah bring out some of the the anguish
and the sorrow in that struggle not just
the annoyed anger the the frustrations
yeah so uh but then she had a really
great scene with lois at the end like i
i think that what caught me by surprise
was the reveal of why lois is so upset
um because it's like obviously there's
something more going on here uh but it
wasn't
it wasn't like obvious to the point of
why she's
behaving that way and then how they
linked it to her past i thought was
really
great because
it i i appreciate the writing of
that because logically
we could sit here
clark could listen to her
and go well that's not the same yeah
what's your deal you know
why are you misconstruing these things
jeez what's wrong with you what's wrong
with you you're being that bad you're
being stupid
stop now i mean that's not the reaction
we had obviously no uh
it's but it is so real
that
logic is not really thrown into the
equation here that it's more of the
emotional triggers on at hand and i
think that's what makes that so strong
and rich
is we we can sit here and logically go
well that's not the same thing um
but also completely understand how she
correlates the two on a subconscious
level well i think they're really good
at that kind of dialogue especially
because that was that's why the natalie
was more upsetting didn't we yeah yeah
yeah and it's a theme across this
episode of like characters yeah and not
being ready to talk about what their
actual feelings are being afraid to
reveal what's truly bothering them
etcetera and i think
and i thought you got a really good
representation of that across everybody
and and the natalie story yeah was the
one that stuck out until the end but
overall i feel like what they're good at
doing
the first season was exemplary of this
and especially the lowest scenes here
uh is just the psychology of that
writing where where
i feel like you know you're reverse
engineering as a writer these situations
a lot of the time you know what the root
is and then you're kind of working your
way back to the sort of you know way the
characters figuring it out in dialogue
and i think they're really good at
writing those things where you can tell
okay this isn't what's truly the matter
at hand but this is what's bothering you
and i love those layers
and i love that even though this episode
did feel like we're kind of jumping
right back in and there's you know
already a good amount of like you know
sci-fi mystery at hand i like the way
that they drew that between clark and
lois and you know had their conflict and
resolution by the end
and worked in the boys you know get a
little family like intimate family stuff
some you know multiversal family stuff
and then of course doomsday yeah yeah
i mean uh
yeah he's just not going to do that at
home ever again
he's going to go out to the pond next
week
and then why don't you lock your door
man
yeah
it's like 101.
lock your door if you're gonna do it
against the door yeah if you're gonna do
it anyway
like take a precaution
you know you would rather have to do the
like what sorry you didn't know it was
locked than than that you know then yeah
when i go to a public restroom
where it's like it's a restaurant and
there's only one
toilet
it's like which is unreasonable by the
way
why for everyone you only have one table
this is a whole digestive situation what
if you got a packed restaurant
yeah
yeah that's a bad idea
and then it's one of those locks that's
like a push there's like little thin
locks you know i'm talking about where
you're like
i think it's
right can you try the door on the other
side just to make sure whoever's waiting
in line
yeah i put a trash can and move the
trash in front of the door oh yeah
in case someone pushes it open yeah
especially in a public environment yeah
you didn't want that trauma in your life
so jonathan be wiser man this is why
you're not playing on the football team
when you're about to when you're about
to make love just act like you're taking
a dump just block the door all caught
the door
taking a dump in a public restaurant
guys to your man and lois
we're here it's a fun show we didn't
miss it
all right two more to go then we're
caught up dude we can do this
all ten thousand views oh tattoos
they're gonna be the most quality view
hundred percent watch time
what is the review gonna say that's all
everybody wants to know
i skipped your reaction to hear your
thoughts
oh [ __ ] i already saw the show with your
review
thank you guys that's so sweet let's go